das elektrische universum oft auch als
plasma version bezeichnet ist ein
universum in dem die vorgänge im kosmos
nicht von der gravitation bestimmt
sondern von der elektromagnetischen
kraft sterne beispielsweise sollen durch
elektrizität betrieben werden das bild
des kosmos dass wir seit jahrhunderten
haben wird also komplett auf den kopf
gestellt was steckt wirklich hinter
dieser hypothese und welche pro und
contra argumente gibt es bezüglich eines
plasma versus und ist tatsächlich unser
wissen zur gesamten naturwissenschaft
falsch ihr habt vielleicht schon eine
ahnung dass alles noch viel mehr jetzt
in klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen
ein themenvorschlag über die messenger
whatsapp und so weiter vielen dank dafür
wer dabei sein könnt und themen
vorschlagen können und vor allem die
unzuverlässige abo box von youtube
überlistet das erfahrt ihr am ende des
videos das eine modell zum elektrischen
universum oder zur plasma kosmologie
gibt es nicht wirklich statt dessen gibt
es unzählige filme bücher und
behauptungen dazu die sich in den
einzelheiten allerdings stark
unterscheiden
auch wo genau der ursprung dieser idee
zum universum liegt es ungewiss 883
jedenfalls wurde ein aufsatz zum thema
in neuseeland von einem autoren mit dem
pseudonym torpedo verfasst ich sage
explizit aufsatz
denn hierbei handelt es sich keinesfalls
um irgendeine wissenschaftliche arbeit
demnach ist die elektrizität für alles
im universum verantwortlich erst durch
elektrische vorgänge können die sterne
leuchten und sie die planeten bewegen
auch weitere arbeiten zum elektrischen
universum auf die sich ihre anhänger
berufen stammen nicht von astronomen
oder astronomen physikern oder
physikerin das ganze netz ist voll von
seiten auf denen verschiedene thesen zum
thema aufgestellt werden einig sind sich
die anhänger und anhängerinnen aber
zumindest in den folgenden punkten im
elektrischen universum gibt es kein
urknall stattdessen wird behauptet dass
das universum viel kleiner sei als
angenommen und zudem statisch b auch die
sterne werden durch elektrizität
angetrieben der hypothese des
elektrischen universums zufolge sind
sterne elektrische transformatoren zu
dem gebären sie elektrisch andere sterne
und gasplaneten so entstehen auch
erdähnliche planeten um und zwar durch
einen elektrischen ausstoß aus gas
giganten planeten neben umlaufbahn an
die der geringsten elektrischen
beeinflussung entsprechen
ja das universum expandiert nicht und
galaxien bestehen aus elektrizität die
krater auf himmelskörpern sind spuren
elektrische entladung die die großen
gaswolken und supernova reste sind
plasma ströme im universum
ihr merkt also was die moderne
astronomie seit jahrzehnten annimmt ist
nach den vorstellungen der anhänger des
elektrische universums falsch demnach
ist einfach alles elektrizität
forschungsteams weltweit jedenfalls
sehen das alles als eine große
verschwörungstheorie gemischt mit ein
10 pseudowissenschaft und darüber haben
wir in anderen videos von kriegs- und
science fiction ja zur genüge berichtet
verschwörungstheorien sind so abstrus
dass es schwerfällt angemessen darauf zu
reagieren quasi so als wenn euch jemand
erzählen würde
das gras ist nicht grün sondern lila was
soll man anfangen mit solchen argumenten
doch fest steht die theorie des
elektrischen universums widerlegt
komplett unser wissen und die forschung
zu den gravitative wechselwirkung und
sind wir mal ehrlich damit lassen sich
alle phänomene auf der erde erklären die
mit schwerkraft zu tun haben auch die
bewegung der himmelskörper wie lässt
sich damit vorhersagen und sogar neue
planeten lassen sich mit diesem wissen
ich sag nur planet 10x oder 9 oder wie
wir und auch immer nennen wollen damit
konnten wir 2006 eine raumsonde in
richtung eines leeren punkte schicken
weil wir berechnen konnten dass sie dort
zehn jahre später auf pluto treffen wird
natürlich kann es sein dass wir die
gravitation noch nicht zu 100 prozent
verstanden und beschrieben haben aber
natürlich lässt das nicht den
umkehrschluss zu dass alles dazu falsch
ist dazu kommt die theorie des
elektrischen universums beschreibt den
kosmos nicht mal annähernd so gut es
gibt keine mathematische formel mit der
man beispielsweise die bewegungen der
planeten so gut vorhersagen kann wie mit
unserem wissen zur gravitation und das
wurde jahrzehntelang durch
unterschiedliche beobachtungen methoden
bestätigt und herausgefunden viele
anhänger und anhängerinnen sind der
ansicht dass sich seriöse
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
extra unsinnigen theorien zum universum
ausdenken um die angeblichen fakten zum
elektrischen universum zu unterdrücken
ein beispiel in einem aufsatz heißt es
dass sonnenflecken kühler sind als ihre
umgebung doch dies würde von der
modernen astronomie geleugnet
stattdessen hätten sonnenflecken etwas
mit elektrizität zu tun deswegen sei
auch die sonne elektrisch wir alle
wissen aber dass moderne forschungsteam
sehr wohl beobachtungen und messungen
dazu machen und natürlich ignorieren sie
die kühleren temperaturen der
sonnenflecken nicht genauso wenig wie
sie magnetische und elektrische felder
in ihren erklärungen auch nicht
ignorieren
ja doch nur weil dieser teilt eine
theorie ist heißt es noch lange nicht
das alles elektromagnetisch ist eines
muss lernen den anhängern des
elektrischen universums lassen ihre
hypothesen sind simpel und genau das
wird auch der grund sein weswegen ihre
anhänger lieber an sie
als an komplizierte wissenschaftliche
erklärungen glauben aber mal ganz
ehrlich wie sollten sich
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
so komplexe theorien mit mathematischen
riesigen konstruktionen ausdenken können
wenn sie keinen realen hintergrund
hätten ja wenn ihr kein video zur
bullshit theorien und zu einem anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich
beim whatsapp und den anderen messengern
nur dann verpasst er kein video denn die
abo box auf youtube das wisst ihr ja die
ist immer ziemlich lückenhaft über die
messenger erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor
allen anderen vom neuesten videos liegt
also vorher eine nachricht täglich
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
zur begrüßung habe ich ein kleines
goodie für euch und am besten auch
meinen schwesterkanal krieg zum social
media abonnieren es geht auch hier darf
hat er das neueste aus der social media
welt aktuell die anhörung von mark
zuckerberg vor dem europäischen
parlament aber nicht die glocke einen
job aber nicht genau wie glocke
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken kopf einschalten
bei schwert verschwörungstheorien
das kann ich nur wärmstens empfehlen
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran